all right we are now live for another
dr. Sadler's philosophy pop up let me
make sure the sound stuff is is all set
up right my son was on this computer
over the weekend and and there's always
some things that will end up being a
little wonky when he uses things okay
there we go
so it looks like the volumes right and I
see looking over in the chat window a
great painter from Michael you all know
the drill if you want to be confident
your question is addressed by dr.
Sandler it's a good idea to submit early
here you're in the chance I'll come back
to those questions that is quite true
it's always better to put it earlier
than later because they they tend to
pile up so I thought you know I hadn't
gotten around this is an extraordinarily
busy month to coming up with a topic and
then actually I wound up with with one
eye in an unfortunate way suggesting
itself to me we had to put down our dog
Magnus this weekend and he's 14 years
old really wasn't living a life as as
himself more than moments at a time I
mean there was still a lot of him him
left but it was you could say greatly
impeded and so that was a big tough
thing over this Thanksgiving weekend for
all of us but especially for my wife and
as it also turned out for my my son my
wife raised him from a puppy so they'd
been together his entire life and our
other dog just adjust that has known him
her entire life just about because she
actually was a puppy who he picked out
so it got me thinking I've got a book
project that I've been working on
really since another animal had to be
put down several years ago and I'll tell
you about that in just a minute but I
was also thinking about something that
we'd call the paradox of care something
I'll be doing a bit of writing about and
our exes do you know idk my main blog
probably over the course of this week
and I also was thinking you know a lot
about the nature of our relationship
with animals so I thought I'd just go on
for a little bit talking about that
before taking my first couple ones yeah
so the whole title is dr. Sadler is
philosophy pop up after putting down a
beloved dog Magnus some people are
saying you know sorry to hear that and
yeah it would use a good dog so let me
talk about the the paradox of care first
and and there may be you know another
name for this out there somewhere in the
philosophical literature I haven't you
know done sort of a survey of the
available literature to find out if you
know somebody else has already covered
these discussions or anything along
those lines yet but I will be for this
book project that I'm working on what I
have in mind by by talking about the
paradox of care is as you give better
care you wind up extending the life and
a lot of other values to say mobility
and and the possibility of interacting
for and we'll talk about in terms of
animals here although this could apply
to people too you end up extending all
of these things for the animal by giving
really good care and the more care that
you give that's not as if there's a
direct one-to-one relationship but the
more care that you give the better their
outcomes are and for an animal who's you
know like at the midpoint of their life
that's really great you know you can
think about like when you take a animal
to the veterinarian you want really good
care for them
you know if you have somebody watching
your your animal in a period of
convalescence or when you're on a
vacation the better care they get the
better it is for them but when you're
close to the end of their life you're
because of the good care that you're
giving at that time and perhaps even
because of the good care that you gave
prior to that you're extending their
lifetime beyond what it naturally would
be and then all sorts of other problems
and predicaments can start to arise and
in animals it's quite often in terms of
organ failure you know like if you have
a cat you know what the vets tell us is
their organs are good for about 12 years
and then beyond that it's kind of
touch-and-go and I think you can say the
same thing about dogs although you know
with dogs there's also the factor of
size older dogs tend not to live as long
smaller dogs live longer I'm not exactly
sure why I'm sure it has something to do
with organs and the stress on them but
the paradox is you're giving care
because you love the animal or you you
feel a sense of compassion or sympathy
or or whatever it happens to be and
you're doing something that is
objectively a good thing and it is a
good thing none of the you know the fact
that it may not pay off or might might
extend their life in ways that make them
suffer none of that takes away from the
goodness of the action or the intention
or the motivation or character that it's
coming from but it can lead to outcomes
that are in some respect tougher all
around and so precisely by doing what we
feel to be the right thing and the good
thing were then placed into a situation
and the animals placed into a situation
where we eventually have to start making
difficult decisions and that's the
paradox right things don't turn out the
way that we would expect that they they
do and so I'm going to do a bit more
writing and
that and I thought I would just sort of
throw that out there is an interesting
feature of our moral life and our
interaction with pets and before I had
talked about leaving all of our
interactions with pets things I just
want to point out one thing which is you
know when you take on a puppy or a
kitten or I don't know whatever you're
gonna have a tarantula a snake a ferret
for most animals when you get it you
know that animal is not going to live as
long as you are so you know if you treat
it right if you unless there's some sort
of accident you're going to have to
figure out what to do with it when it
starts getting into its old age and
starts getting sick and and unhappy and
suffering and loses mobility and perhaps
you know has to be cleaned up after much
more often or doesn't recognize you the
way that it used to that's that's part
of what comes with being a good pet
owner I mean there's there's all sorts
of ways in which people buy pets and
then don't take care of them when I
lived in southern Illinois it was common
to see college students who would buy a
puppy or a kitten and then they would
abandon it quite quit you know
frequently at the end of the semester as
they went up to back to Chicago and left
it down there and it would wander around
you know looking for affection and food
and eventually find a new person that's
how I actually got one of my cats the
other thing that I was going to talk
about with it was the book project that
I've been working on so I should say a
little bit about that and then I'll I'll
jump into these questions and comments
so it was years ago leading up until you
know Christmastime we had a cat who
ultimately had liver failure and we
didn't know what was going on at the
time she started out by getting finicky
about her food she wasn't very old she
was she was on the older side but she
wasn't you know like twelve thirty you
know 13 14 15 25 anything like that and
so anyway she stopped eating and then we
switched the food and she needs a bit
more of that
and then you know she'd stop eating that
and we were getting worried about her so
we eventually took her into the the
veterinarian's office and they started
doing tests on her it wasn't you know it
was not pleasant for the cat to be
boarded up and kept away from home and
have pokes and prods and be lonely and
all that and eventually it came out that
her liver was failing and there really
wasn't anything that we could do and we
had to make a very difficult decision
because we've gotten to the point where
we'd already spent you know quite a lot
of money to get these tests done and get
you know some alleviation perhaps of
what was going on but nothing that could
actually stem the tide and the next step
would be to send her up to Albany where
she would be in like a special Hospital
and it was going to be about $500 a day
and there was no guarantee that any of
this would any of these these drastic
remedies would turn things around and so
you know we had to sit down and decide
okay this is the time to euthanize her
and it was it was a tough decision and
seeing my wife going through this
decision and the talking that we had and
seeing that the the vets really you know
they could they could give you a bit of
advice but they weren't really that well
equipped for that I thought you know I
teach ethics for a living
somebody should write a book about how
to make these sorts of decisions and not
like a textbook write something that
would be a handy guide for people as
they're going through this
decision-making process to make it you
know to raise the sorts of questions
that other people might be afraid to
raise like you know maybe you should in
fact have like a certain financial
threshold where you like well you know
fluffy gets this much and beyond that
we're not going there and then you know
should you feel guilty about that or
should you say this is a prudent thing
to do those are the sorts of things that
we we don't have very good discussions
about because we don't actually train
people to do it and you know in
in hospitals we do have medical
ethicists in some hospitals usually that
gets like pushed off to the unfortunate
doctors who are definitely not equipped
to handle it or to the chaplains who
oftentimes we're out of their depth as
well but we don't have anything like
this for veterinarians and I've been
talking you know with people in the
veterinary industry from time to time
when I you know do a little bit of
progress on the book saying do you think
something like this would be helpful for
you do you think something like this
would be helpful for your clients and
the the response is always yeah this
would be great I mean it wouldn't cover
everything nothing can cover everything
but it would sure as hell be better than
what's available which right now as far
as I can tell is almost nothing so
that's that's a project I actually
started outlining the book couple shut
up and writes you know this writing
thing that we host here in Milwaukee a
couple shut up in write sessions ago I
devoted a time just putting together an
outline and I'm gonna start working on
the book you know I was spending quite a
bit of time doing caretaking of one sort
or another with Magnus so I can take
that time instead and work on that book
and I think it would be you know a good
project I've got other writing things I
have to be working on as well as well as
shooting videos and things like that but
I think this would be a you know real
labor of love in some respects and you
know as an ethicist I think this is a
good project to take on for me so
curious to see what people think about
that maybe I'm gonna address a few
questions and comments and then maybe if
if we have a lo I'll talk about you know
sort of my reflections on human beings
and our relations with the animals
if not we'll just go with the questions
so Christopher I just wanted to say
thank you for the content the formal
education has been in biology but I'm so
studying philosophy now on my own is it
helps paint a clear picture of what
no scientifically well it's really great
to read yeah somebody you probably would
enjoy reading that if you don't already
know about him is one of my colleagues
Massimo Pigliucci who first PhD and then
eventually went on and earned another
degree in philosophy he wrote quite a
few things about biology at first and
yeah the philosophy when it's done well
that's the key thing there right when
it's done well it's not a dilettante
game when it's not you know people
having academic doing their tiny little
project that has nothing to do with when
it's doing its job well it should
actually provide some sort of context
for the sciences that that helps them
understand what they're doing not a lot
of money in a k-12 fortunately so not
too many people do it let's see what
else we got going on here people are
saying hello all right looks like we got
a lot of questions just sort of jumped
all over the place well here's a
question that I can't actually answer
much of what are the implications of
general relativity for countless
transcendental idealism it seems as if
my space and time can be modified by
phenomena they themselves are phenomenal
and not transcendental I mean they could
still be transcendental just
transcendental in a different way than
they are for for Kant they you know
they're definitely not space and time
are definitely not the same thing as the
things that fill space and I would say
but it's not something that I do a lot
of work on made of clay how do you feel
about Paul Tillich well telic is a kind
of funny guy for a couple reasons
so Tillich was really big stuff when I
was an undergraduate but that was in
part because my undergraduate professors
were so far behind the times that they
thought that existentialism was you know
the end of continental philosophy and
Tillich is okay the courage to be is not
a bad book
I think that as far as existentialist
thinkers go he's not a really profound
one but he's not terrible I'll tell you
another thing that was you know kind of
funny about him they they found that he
had quite a stash of erotic images after
he died and people were very surprised
about that
peril by a zazzy own thoughts on zoe
astron ism and its influence on Judaism
and Christianity yeah I used to teach
about so astron ism when I taught world
religion classes and so I had to do you
know as I do with any class that I teach
where I'm not already well-versed and I
had to do a lot of research on the topic
and I was surprised to find out just how
much influence though Astron ism had
exerted on later Judaism and then
thereby on Christianity and so how did
that influence happen well remember ism
is associated with with Persian and when
you know you had the separated Kingdom
and in in in Israel to the north and
then Judea with the two tribes in the
south and the Assyrians come in and
destroy the Kingdom of Israel and start
you know transplanting people there and
there
then the Babylonians and the you know
they defeat the Assyrians and then you
have the Babylonian captivity right
which means that the Babylonians this is
very common in ancient times if you
wanted to make sure that if people
stayed conquered you could do a couple
different things one was just bringing a
whole bunch of other people like what
happened in you know the northern part
of the kingdom where all these other
people are brought in and you know sort
of intermixed with the Israelites and
that's how you got the Samaritans who
then were considered unclean and and you
know not not real Jews and heretical and
all these other things by from the
people in the South that was from the
Assyrians the Babylonians did something
different they were like well let's just
take all the elites you know and we'll
transport them to Bab
and then everybody who's left on the
land will just keep their mouth shut and
not give us any problem so so they did
that and then the Persians conquered the
Babylonians Persians and Medes right and
then the Persians under there their
first main empire brought all those
Jewish exiles back and allowed the the
you know people of Jerusalem to rebuild
their walls for this Cyrus was called
The Anointed of the Lord the only
Gentile as far as I know who gets called
The Anointed of the Lord in those older
documents that we call the Old Testament
or the Hebrew Scriptures and because of
that Zoe astron ISM exerts a significant
influence on you know Jewish religion
and and thoughts about things so like
the idea of Hell being a fiery place
comes from so Astron ISM so Astron ISM
had a savior figure called the South
shot now they had a different you know
understanding of how it would work but
you know there's a lot of different
aspects of it that make their way and I
think that's kind of cool like Judaism
and Christianity it really stresses a
ethical code there is arguably a
monotheistic core Chuzhou Astron ism
sometimes we go and say dualism but
really that's sort of I would say sort
of a what no astron ism sometimes became
rather than the core of it so yeah very
very interesting stuff I actually had a
professor who is as oh Astron ism though
astron when I was in college and so I
was fortunate enabled getting to talk
with him about contemporary zou astron
ISM that was maragon Kota Von D who
retired last year I met him again when I
was up at Lakeland about a year and a
half ago and he was you know on his way
out because he was older so alright
let's see here
kevin costner my dog passed away a
couple months ago is the most difficult
tragedy to push through sorry for your
loss yeah that's it is it is a tough
thing dealing with the death of a pet
and it's in in some ways it's tougher
when you have to make the decision
yourself you know or as a group about
ending the the pets life as opposed to
an accident happening right an accident
happening that sucks that's terrible but
when you have to be involved with it
then there's all these other issues that
they come about right let's see when we
hear more and more questions a lot of
stuff about other dogs who've died all
right so joking some people suggest
owning died owning pets as property is
in some way equivalent to slavery
obviously this analogy seems overblown
although there seem to be some
similarities any thoughts well
the way some people treat their animals
is certainly like you know slavery right
and and and we could think of I think
it's really helpful to think of this
using ancient philosophy particularly
you know think about Aristotle who he
gets a lot of heat for you know talking
about there being some people slaves by
nature he doesn't actually think most
most slaves are slaves by nature he
thinks they're slaves by convention and
he talks about technology and he says
that we're it possible for the Loom to
weave itself we wouldn't need any of
these and sold tools that we call slaves
and that's exactly what technology does
and we're posed with some of the same
questions now a lot of people treat
animals as if they're technology as if
they don't have feelings as if they
don't have any you know you could say
likenesses to us in in things that count
and maybe some of them don't have very
much of that maybe
you know if we go down the order of
things maybe we don't have to be that
concerned about incense although you
know the more we observe animal behavior
the more we start to see maybe there are
some things that maybe there are
attachments maybe there are feelings
that we weren't taking it for you know
into account as we start moving up into
birds and mammals man it there are a lot
of people treating animals as if they're
just dumb brute machines who are in
effect treating them as if they are you
know merely merely slaves you know
subject solely to our whims only
important because of that and I think
we're starting to realize at least some
of us that that's that's that's
wrongheaded doesn't mean that we have to
say they're totally equal to us you know
I think when you try to say oh I'm
getting rid of speciesism altogether man
that just turns into a massive crap it
becomes almost impossible to make any
decision then but yeah that's that's a
good point
all right can I can I gal V the book
sounds interesting in on the topic of
writing do you have any advice on how to
outline books or get started in writing
um well the best way to get started in
writing is start writing right because
you're gonna write a lot of stuff yeah
very good but that's how you get better
you also need to read a lot too and have
other people review your writing and go
through the the difficult process of
them saying this sucks and here's why it
sucks in here here's how you can make it
better and you will become a better
writer so part of the process of
becoming a better writer is learning how
to deal with a lot of rejection in
productive ways and then you know how to
outline things you know I like just what
is each chapter supposed to be doing and
does the order of the chapters make
sense
there's no right length for for books
you know it totally depends on the topic
and the audience and what the book is
intended to achieve all of those sorts
of things you know some books are very
short and very good other books are
quite lengthy and
need to be quite lengthy you know we
live in a wonderful time too because in
the past you're basically stuck either
with self-publishing which was seen as a
luxury vanity thing and you paid a lot
of money for it or with having to pitch
your stuff to an academic press or to
trade you know presses and there you
were stuck with whatever they wanted to
do you know now the the opprobrium about
self-publishing has gone away and if you
want to you know try to produce a book
that's 800 pages go ahead you know
nobody's gonna stop you you know it may
not sell it as well as shorter books but
you can do it so we live in a really
great time for that
phantom upload is a very generic
question what is power I don't know
there's a lot of definitions out there
the capacity may be to produce effects
to get things done
20:46 best-selling text to deal with the
topic of death well I mean there's a lot
of discussions and epictetus and marcus
aurelius that are that are particularly
germane and in Seneca particularly in
his letters but Seneca also has letters
of consolation to particular people
those are the ones I would look at all
right and Adam what to do if you're
interested in so many things you can't
choose anything to be an expert in well
keep cracking at those and maybe one of
them you know right now isn't suggesting
itself to you but as you reach a higher
level of expertise maybe that will draw
you in there's a question about crime
and punishment
why does Aliona the pawnbroker call
rush-rush alone Acuff father I don't
know I haven't read the book for quite a
while I'm not sure why people ask
questions like that here
all right Kevin I find it strange we
ethically weigh the correct decision for
euthanizing pets were ill by referring
to the probability of recovery time and
affordability to the owner that seems
immoral
it doesn't seem immoral to me at all
most decisions that we make in life we
have to weigh a number of different
incommensurable Goods against each other
that's what makes them difficult
decisions you know when we have the
luxury of having easy ethical decisions
that's that's wonderful but that's
pretty rare most of the important
decisions we have to weigh things like
that against each other and so the
question is not to like this trip all
those away and say there are moral
question is to try to get those
decisions right or at least more right
made of clay why is anti-semitism still
a thing another very big question well
you know I would say we're always gonna
have people who want to find somebody
else to blame about things and we're
always going to have sort of what would
you call it you know stupid prejudices
around because there's always gonna be
somebody repeating them you know why is
racism still a thing in general I mean
by this point in time we should be
beyond that and there's gonna be
somebody as races are natural or some
some other you know basically
warmed-over 19th century racism Galba no
style thing and there's your answer
people like to have these sorts of
things to motivate them I can tell you
this that if you've actually got
something productive to do with your
life you're not going to be an
anti-semite or a racist or you know
[Music]
discriminate against other people is
going to be too busy like trying to do
good things to just you know screw
around with stuff like that
7:26 Twister are you an antenatal is
what do you think about it I'm not an
antenatal list I think you know an
antenatal astiz somebody who thinks that
we shouldn't we shouldn't have any more
children born and it's a bad thing to be
born and all that and I mean I would say
we should try to improve the conditions
for the children stuck in this this
world that we managed that bollocks up
pretty pretty good
but I'm definitely not an antenatal list
I certainly made my contribution to
continuing the species I have two kids
myself
so Kevin Kasten are you a moral realist
I don't know when people usually ask me
are you an S the answer is usually no
because these are things that can mean
whatever you want there's usually like a
lot of ambiguity in these terms but if
you mean by moral realist that I think
that there are actual objective
standards of value out there that are
independent of discourse or things like
that sure but that doesn't mean that I
don't think that language doesn't matter
or culture doesn't matter anything like
that so it depends on what kind of more
moral realist you're talking about Floyd
fanatic are you familiar with what's
called depressive realism in psychology
what if any are the it's philosophical
implications epistemological
metaphysically or ethically I haven't
heard that word but I may have come
across that concept because a lot of
things in psychology wind up being the
same old stuff repackaged and called
something different
same thing by the way for business
theory and theory lots of stuff is just
the same thing so yeah I don't know I'm
gonna skip over the Noam Chomsky cuz I
know I've talked about that many times
before ways to overcome skepticism from
Adam Teitur well there aren't really
ways to overcome skepticism there isn't
like a you know argument that you could
give that likes going to convince the
skeptic a lot of those sort of things I
think are manners of putting together a
whole bunch of different experiences and
reflecting on them and maybe there's
times where a person goes through a
skeptical phase and that can be okay
so long as you're not doing things like
saying I don't know if I walk off this
cliff if I will not fall down you know
if you do then like pyro
the skeptic you you really need some
followers to keep you from going off the
cliff joe Brammer my condolences about
Magnus is YouTube more conducive of
producing right-wing thinkers such as
Jordan
person were merely reflective of the
user base or is there a symbiosis going
on well YouTube didn't produce Jordan
Peterson Jordan Peterson became what he
is he
you know wound his wound up being on
YouTube and people watched him and liked
what he had to say and you know shared
it and and actually - you got to
remember that a lot of things that
promote things promote people or causes
are people posting and saying this is
terrible right so there's probably a
good bit of that with the Petersons as
well I wouldn't say that YouTube strikes
me as being any more left-wing than
right wing as a format there's many
youtubers out there on all these
different wings and all other parts of
the spectrum as well I will say this
that I don't think Peterson could have
made it big without YouTube he would've
just been another you know obscure
academic engaging in the kinds of you
know speculative discussions that plenty
of our professors did saying a lot of
the same stuff but he put his stuff on
YouTube and it caught on and people are
like this is really great got to watch
this and then other people started
taking notice of him but what really
catapulted him to fame is stuff outside
of YouTube right being put into other
media and being part of protests Daniel
Cox there's some of your favorite books
on the philosophy of religion you know I
like classic stuff William James's
varieties of religious experience I when
I teach philosophy of religion I have
people read that Rudolph Otto's the
phenomenon of the holy is pretty cool
you know
Gabriele Marcel arguably fits in there's
Josiah Royce
you know usually I'm doing stuff not
that so much books on philosophy of
religion and more you know looking at
the figures and their arguments or
schemes you could say so
Ansem right do a lot of work on him he's
definitely an important person in the
philosophy of religion by the way not
just for the so-called ontological
argument but for a whole bunch of other
reasons as well but he's not like
writing philosophy of religion because
that whole field didn't come into
existence until essentially the 19th
century alright let's see what else we
got here
native clay why do people see cultural
Marxism is out to get us
I guess there's sort of a complicated
answer to that
so there's cultural Marxism in the sense
that the people criticizing cultural
Marxism intended some of the time when
they're being you know not they're not
engaging in flights of fancy or just
emotional language but they're talking
about people who you know wanted to try
to take over the Academy and steer it in
a more leftist manner which is not
really a Marxist manner if you're
actually being technically accurate
about what Marxism is about but in a
broad leftist manner right there are a
lot a lot of leftists in academia and
there's a lot of them think that
academia and they're totally wrong about
this I mean it's funny cuz see the
people outside of academia I'm gonna get
all they get you know all worked up
about how the academics are teaching
this and that they've never stepped into
a college classroom and seen a bunch of
like kids not paying attention to the
teacher especially if the teacher seems
outta touch to them the danger of you
know academic cultural marxism
indoctrinating our students man you know
there's there's a few places where that
happens but that's so far removed from
the reality of universities and colleges
that the people who are talking about it
just oughta just shut up and go and
spend some time in actual classrooms and
pay attention without going in with
their own ideological blinders and they
feel a lot less fearful alright so
there's all there right and the royal
plenty of academics who are on the Left
close minded shut conversation down you
know means justify the end sort of sort
of people and then there's this broader
critique of cultural Marxism
that's basically fine-spun [ __ ] you
know where where it's essentially an
emotional term that people are using
without knowing very much about Marxism
itself or sometimes they want
post-modernism in there too and again
they're creating a boogeyman that they
can use to scare people and justify
being scared themselves so all right
the Floyd fanatic any thoughts on
Umberto eCos concept of fascism I would
say it's wrong and calling itself era
fascism because that implies it like
he's got at the root of it there are a
lot of great discussions about what goes
into what we call the fascist minimum
right have power or something like that
you know we need to recognize the
difference between say a military
dictatorship and actual fascist regimes
you know where you've got mobilization
of the masses you know an attempt to
overcome class divisions all those those
sorts of aspects to it a lot of
conservative regimes are not fascist
echoes si is good I actually I use it
when I talk about fascism I would not
rely on it as the sole set of criteria
for it Adam asks are you good at chess I
am not good at chess as a matter of fact
I played some games with my 11 year old
son and I beat him and won and lost too
and we actually had a draw because I
wasn't paying attention to where I was
putting my pieces and put him into a
stalemate position by mistake so yeah
all right 21st century dove back to
animal stuff I had a puppy get hit by a
car a few years ago died in the street I
had to get a towel and pick it up off
the street and bury her myself tough for
sure yeah especially when it's a puppy
you know and we say something similar I
think to about about human beings you
know when when somebody who's quite old
and sick dies
you know sometimes sometimes we're very
sad about it by the way Lauren if you
don't
yeah a lot a lot of recent deaths of
important people in the news lately but
so we get very upset when a young person
dies because we're like ha they had
their whole life ahead of them they were
their prime things were going good for
them you know I actually had a dog when
I was a kid I'll tell you a little story
I won't make it too long I had a dog
named Lady and when she was probably
four or five years old she got hit by a
car right by our house and she was a
black dog and you know we lived in an
unlit area so it's you know no harm no
fault but and the person who hit her
actually I came to the house immediately
and said you know we hit your dog and
she ran about a hundred yards on a
broken hip and then collapsed and so you
know my my dad went and got his car and
got ahold of the vet and then I he sent
me out with a blanket to stay with her
and keep her warm and then he and a
couple of the other guys from the
neighborhood
put the blanket under her and got her
into the car and took her to the vet and
then at the vets he gave us a choice to
make he said listen we can have
Christmas or we can replace lady's hip
if we're not replacing her hip then
we're gonna put her to sleep so you
decide and we decided not to have
Christmas we ended up having Christmas
anyway I don't know you know something
must have happened but it was you know
pretty expensive operation at the time
and when she came back you know her hip
was shaved she had this plastic
implant and she didn't want to eat and
it took a long time to coax her and get
her back to going again but you know all
right
Luka mer makes a point it's weird having
to clean up my slaves poop and vomit you
know it's kind of funny in ancient times
if you actually read literature about
slaves or servants or stuff people often
think all you had to blossom around do
whatever you want I mean read epictetus
who by the way was a slave
and then had a servant himself later you
know at one point and and and and see
what he has to say about just the
hassles associated with managing other
people
Joe Houseman what's your general opinion
on the utility of psychoanalysis and
aiding our understanding of philosophic
or ethical issues
well my general opinion is that
psychoanalysis I think there's a lot of
nutty psychoanalysts out there I think
there's a lot of people who don't know
psychoanalytic theory well particularly
with LeConte
and then try to you know push it into
cultural theory and just blather a bunch
of nonsense you know film theories full
of that sort of stuff it has been for
for several generations I don't think
that we should throw psychoanalysis out
altogether I think things like you know
the Oedipus complex we could probably
get rid of at this point but you know
there's a lot of a lot of useful
insights and I think sometimes some of
the things that psychoanalysis does in
depth psychology in general does can be
useful in getting getting people to work
through traumas that say CBT can't get
to you know and so it could be you know
useful in some respects catalysis MO and
ecclesia militants thought of
post-mortem repentance and Christianity
as it possible I don't have any and you
know that sort of thing you know
memento mori what's your thoughts on
free will and moral responsibility I
think we have free will I don't think
it's what many of the opponents of free
will think free will is I think it's
probably a lot more limited and I think
it's actually something that we can
expand through intentional ways of
living and I think philosophies as way
of life are ways of doing that that's
one of the things that attracts me to
stoicism Adam you don't usually talk
about analytic philosophy why do you
prefer continental ists well I don't
prefer continental estar Continentals
I am actually a historian of philosophy
if you look through my channel you're
gonna find way more stuff on ancient
philosophy than you are on any
contemporary continental stuff and you
know I I do in fact like some analytic
philosophers John wisdom I've talked
about many times I enjoy you know I
started writing my master's thesis on
Vidkun Stein the only reason I didn't
finish it is
I couldn't get my advisor to actually
understand what I was what I was trying
to do and yeah I mean I I like quite a
few analytic philosophy things and I
sometimes teach a bit of that and I'm
not you know a fan of many continents
philosophers I often joke and maybe I
will someday do it I want to write a
book someday as chapters like what in
so-and-so is [ __ ] and what's
actually good you know and do that for
all these these continental figures but
I mean on the whole problems with
contemporary analytics is they don't
read very much the ones that do quit
being analytics pretty pretty quickly
they they wind up doing other things you
know and they they're trained in how to
you know examine arguments and how to
create accounts of things but they're
not getting trained in in much of
anything else and they they want it
being very insular and provincial and I
don't like that in any field I mean what
good is that so
I mean continental that's a problem too
you know but analytics are the ones who
more or less run though in the show
[Music]
Catholics see small your thoughts on
Jordan Peterson's act as if God would
exist it sounds sort of like Pascal's
wager or James's will to believe I don't
know I mean I don't go to Peterson for
thing like that
memento mori had a follow up and if
you're a compatibilist do you think
unfree action is impossible in the human
view of reason which is opposed to
plato's there's no evaluative power that
is our different shades of the self
needed for compatible is moral
responsibility yeah you know I am pretty
much a compatibles when it comes to the
metaphysics of the will I don't accept a
human view of reason though I think
reason can actually do a lot more than I
think reason not only can do a lot more
than Hume made room for I think human
himself uses reason to do more than that
so here is he wasn't he was inconsistent
[Music]
yeah all right theology of the body is
another one I'm gonna have to move on to
other people because there's so many
questions
theology of the body by john paul ii
what are your thoughts haven't read it
for over a decade i was never you know
the stuff that i was always interested
in by john paul was before he became
john paul and was carol voltea and wrote
like the acting person or the the
encyclicals that he wrote that i think
are good Nathan have you read any mocks
Turner if so what's your take on his
work I have read mocks Turner yeah and
and I've actually I haven't taught him
but I've been commissioned to do
tutorials on him by people that are into
X Turner interesting guy he's got got a
very interesting take on you know sort
of historical progression I think that
what he's doing and what Nietzsche are
doing are similar in some respects when
I'm when I'm discussing egoism sometimes
if I have you know sophisticated in an
off class I'll bring him up as an
example and he's like totally consistent
with his his a he Co ISM I would say all
right let's go on chinlock leaders
culture get in the way of equality some
cultures are you know about equality so
I don't know why culture would
necessarily get in the way of equality
but depends on sort of depends on what
you mean by culture if you mean like
having high culture that requires a lot
of people to spend
you know there are time resources to
build something up yeah maybe but it
depends on what kind of kind of question
so Daniel Cox is complaining here I open
up and ask a question specifically about
losing a dog and you ignore it what a
joke I'm not sure I skipped a question I
certainly answered his question about oh
here it is
yeah I mean man you know email me about
that sort of stuff you know this is not
the place to like it Patti and pissy
with me okay if you had to put your
childhood dog down last month that's the
first time you cried in years how well I
buried a lot of people and a lot of
animals you know and I started doing
that when I was before my teens so I
don't think our experiences are gonna be
all that commensurate you deal with
death you know it gets easier I think as
you get older and you deal with more of
it but it's never easy you just learn to
deal with them you know yeah crying is
fine I mean there's I remember there's
this book when I was a kid my dad had
called big guys don't cry
right and that was very much the athos
of the 70s and 80s and it was so
liberating for me reading The Odyssey
seeing that Odysseus who you know I
considered a real tough guy
and his crewmates cried over their
crewmates as they're rowing back on
their way not knowing if the longer make
it home
so nothing wrong with crying but you
know I don't think anybody realizes just
how many of these questions I get and
how easy it is to scroll past them so
all right let's take the next one
[Music]
Marco kirilov can we get to the real
morality in moral realism through
language well you're not going to get to
it any other way
you're never going to be able to do
you're never going to be able to put
language entirely aside it is our
primary tool and it's how we communicate
with each other
so I don't see any other prospects for
it unless you're thinking you're gonna
rely on some sort of like intuition or
some sort of programming made of clay
what are your thoughts on religious
fundamentalism
so there's fundamentalism in the strict
sense which was a particular movement
within Protestant Christianity largely
here in America differentiating itself
from Pentecostals and evangelicals and
other people who are biblical
literalists and then there's
fundamentalism sort of lowercase F we're
generally people are talking about
anybody who takes a religious text
literally and I would say you know we're
seeing sort of a resurgence in in some
religions of a kind of fundamentalist
attitude but nobody is it truly a
fundamentalist nobody ever takes any
religious text entirely literally
because it would be impossible to do so
there's there's too many places where
there's ambiguities or verses you can't
totally reconcile with each other so
it's always selective to some degree and
you know the question is can then you
provide some basis for what you're
selecting I will say this a long time
ago I actually read the tracks that the
original fundamentalist capital F
fundamentalists wrote called the
fundamentals and although I didn't agree
with them I could recognize that there
were some pretty interesting biblical
scholars they these were not dummies
some backwoods people just you know as
we say thumping a Bible they they were
you know college educated and they
thought that the way the modernist
readings were going was was off-base
all right chip if you're red blindsight
by Peter Watts I have not so I can't
really say much about that Marco I'm
having trouble doing a logic course do
you have a program for that like
teaching historically Frager Russell
Vidkun Shankar Nappers it better to
tackle the questions paradoxes I don't
know
it depends on your logic course there's
a lot of different ways logic is taught
sounds like from what you're looking at
maybe they're going into the history of
logic I don't know in which case you'd
want to read Mill as well before Fraga
and Russell but do I have a program for
it no I don't know I don't have a course
for core logic be something fun to get
to eventually they ever do but you know
I don't have anything for that it's
something I've taught a number of times
and actually at one time I was kind of
specializing in it when I was an
undergraduate and early in graduate
school but there's there's no one way
that you have to study logic I will say
that if you want to like you know look
at the sort of the the meta logic behind
the logic get kopi he has some good
books not just the textbook but he wrote
some books on like you know sort of the
how logic was working behind its own see
I'm not expressing it well but I mean I
read this when I was when I was an
undergraduate but it really impressed me
he had a book it was really good he was
too you know like where the truth tables
come from and all that sort of stuff
yeah all right
Nikita your mic means adjustment when
you move it cuts out
well it is what it is I don't know what
to tell you
I'm gonna ignore phantom uploads would
you rather I think the son who asks me
those I don't do those all right here we
go Shane Isabel how would movements like
critical race theory which specifically
avoid rationality be viewed in the
context of Hegel's dialectic would it be
external to the dialectic are still part
of it I mean you're asking the question
can you shoehorn it into Hegel's
dialectic and I imagine you mean the
dialectic of the phenomenology rather
than the science of logic all right for
the encyclopedia logic I don't know that
that critical race theory as a whole
specifically avoids rationality it's
often critical of Western rationality
but it employs a rationality of its own
I don't know I mean you could probably
shoehorn it in one part or another of
the phenomenology but you you would I
wouldn't try to shoehorn an entire
movement I would say this person this
this text this thing fits in there right
I don't know so in the beginning acts
about blood meridian i haven't read it
so III don't I don't know enough about
it David you have a video that goes
further in your views on free will
probably not I have a lot of videos on
other people's views on free will
because that's more or less what I do is
present other people's ideas so you know
maybe I'll do my own later on yeah so
21st century dub never heard of John
wisdom what a great name for a
philosopher yeah some of us luck out
getting great names right he certainly
did Marco kirilov do you have opinions
on speculative realism no not really
I've interacted with Graham Harman but
the rest you know I haven't read his
stuff and
I haven't read the other people involved
and it sounds interesting but it's not
something I have a lot of time for for
engaging in ah here's a good historical
question from chip is Millea sand
Cicero's nature the guides a fair
representation of Epicureans or is he
something of a strong man tough to tell
right because we don't have a lot of
representations of Epicureans by at the
koreans but we have is a bit of epic
Epicurus we have and that we only have
because Dabney's narratives wrote this
stuff down line by line thank God and we
have a bit well we have you know
Lucretius and so Lucrecia s-- is giving
us some some good stuff and then who
else do we have you know Phil Adiemus
unfortunately a lot of the stuff that we
found they managed to scrape those
Scrolls and then almost everything is
coming from people who are critical of
the Epicureans I will say this I think
that Cicero treats the Epicureans
unfairly in works like on the ends but
on the nature of the gods I think that's
probably an accurate representation of
epicurean you know views on religion all
right let's see
intellectual dark lab some say we
couldn't really think without language
that's probably right somebody who would
be a proponent to that by the way you
know an actor so so that's an idea
that's been around for a while Jaso if
you still teach at prisons Ivan I have
not taught at a prison since I taught at
Sampson Correctional Institute in North
Carolina and that was in 2009 so it's
almost ten years since I taught in
prisons
and one reason for that is because
prison education around the nation has
been in decline when I was teaching in
Indiana at Indiana State Prison for Ball
State Indiana was the nation's leader in
prison education in a matter of years
they phased out all the be a liberal
arts education replaced it with business
education which then they phased out
they may still have an Ivy Tech in the
prisons but there's no like real serious
prison education there anymore it's
unfortunate you know all right
made of clay have you read any Katherine
Katherine Malibu thoughts yeah I read a
little bit not not that much she
actually teaches that European graduate
school where my wife attended and you
know they've they've had some great
conversations but haven't had time to
get to most of her her stuff
unfortunately seems pretty interesting
so here's a tough question from Jake how
do you give some but someone the desire
to self-actualize well you don't that's
not to say that you can't like keep
throwing stuff out there but there's no
button you can push there's nothing that
you can do that will make a person want
to self-actualize or improve themselves
or look an intentional lifestyle or
anything else that you might say along
those lines
it's unfortunate in a sense right but
it's also good because you know maybe
some of these things have to be people's
own decisions you know I mean I'm sort
of a good example of that I'm somebody
who is quite a screw-up you know a good
portion of of my own young life and many
of the things that people directed me
towards or good advice they gave me I
totally ignored I wasn't ready to hear
it
yeah alright just skipped again there we
go well my condolences losing a pet is
never easy if you read down a [ __ ]
aways the companion species manifesto no
I need that's probably something I need
to read interest dogs people in
significant other 'no saying we're all
cyborgs and her her moment of fame over
that back when i was in graduate school
sort of getting out if i remember right
that would probably be worth checking
out on for me so thanks for that that
recommendation alright so we're at
almost six o'clock and i have to do a
ton of grading unfortunately which is
the worst part about teaching but
absolutely important to do and
absolutely important to take seriously
so i'm going to look for somebody i
haven't answered a question from and and
something that i can actually answer
fairly quickly well here's a good one
this is something i've actually talked
about with one of my clients who I meet
with weekly who was more correct about
human nature in your opinion Rousseau or
Hobbes or is the whole enterprise that's
the part of trying to define human
nature absurd since there are so many
individual variables so let me answer
the second part before I talks you know
specifically about Rousseau and Hans is
the whole enterprise of trying to define
human nature absurd because there's so
many individual variables no and it's
not absurd either but it's a hell of a
lot more complicated than most of the
people who seem to have you know
glib theories about human nature treated
as being so it makes sense that some
people would see it as absurd you can
generalize about human beings in
practical matters and human nature
without necessarily including every
single human being there's going to be
some outliers like Aristotle says
everything in ethics for example is you
know for the most part meaning it
applies in most cases their generality
is not absolutely universal laws because
that's that's we're that kind of
complicated creature it doesn't mean
that we can't generalize about human
nature but we have to be prepared to use
all the resources that we we have at our
disposal and those increase over time
right now we know more about say human
beings and animals through what
zoologists have done and a lot of those
the name is enabled by like you know
video cameras right engaging in
observation of animal behavior so so
that's that's an important point now
about Rousseau and Hobbes I like reading
Hobbes even though I disagree with them
because I think that Hobbes points out
to us a fundamental danger inherent in
in society of a kind of social breakdown
and we want to avoid Hobbesian States
so Hobbes is interesting but Russo's got
some other things on him so it was so
points out that Hobbes generalized about
primitive human beings as if they were
modern human beings just you know remove
all their their their government and
their technology and plunk them down on
an island or something I said no no
human human nature develops over time
and the passions develop over time they
become possible for us in a way that
they weren't for our you know primitive
hominid ancestors it's not just language
that develops it's not just metallurgy
agriculture all this technology that's
developed
social structure it's the very passions
of the human being
Rousseau also says that we have two
other things that separate us from the
other animals and those are free well as
he understands it and a capacity for
self improvement which is very
interesting this isn't the discourse on
the origin of inequality among men right
so I think we're so more on point I'm
not gonna say I like totally endorse
Rousseau's views on things right but
he's more right than Hobbes is but Hobbs
is right about where we could wind up
especially in our contemporary situation
so I'm going to have to go thanks to
everybody for joining me I'll be doing
another philosophy chat later on this
week before the end of the month
same topic I'll be doing that on
Facebook live instead of on YouTube live
so you can find it on my Facebook page I
didn't get to everybody's questions but
I got the quite a few so alright have a
great evening those of you who are over
here some of you in other places have a
great morning middle the night wherever
you happen to be and I'll see you the
next time